[Musique]
il non
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de vip à mes côtés à mickaël
mokongo le joueur de basket de louer ces
trappes saint-quentin-en-yvelines
bonjour michael avant de parler de votre
riche carrière je rappelle que vous avez
35 ans et que vous êtes plus sur la fin
que sur vos débuts on va parler de votre
passion pour ce sport le basket je crois
que ça vient de votre père effectivement
effectuer mon père fut ancien basketteur
ans on en veut plus que centrafricaine
et et il a aussi participé aux jeux
olympiques 92 et je me rappelle quand
elle était partie à son retour c'est là
qu'il a il a amené un panier de basket à
la maison à l'époque j'étais encore un
truc centrafricaine et c'est là il a
instauré un panier j'ai commencé à faire
mes débuts de basketball avec mon père
et mon grand frère donc non vraiment
c'est une histoire de sang c'était
l'époque de la fameuse dream team à
michael jordan et autres ont joué alors
de ces jeux à 2 92
donc c'est vraiment une terrot ce que
moi j'ai bien connu et jordan nous a
tous fait rêver même s'il était plus en
fin de carrière moi je suis plutôt un
fan de kobe bryant alors si vous êtes
arrivé en france racontez nous oui vous
faites moi je suis arrivé en france à
l'âge de
deneuve disons
très très très jeune c'était un peu un
projet familial parce qu'à l'époque il y
avait des autorités de la centrafique
qui disait à mon père que votre fils il
a du talent était déjà brillant c'était
mieux pour lui qu'il a eu en france pour
pour faire carrière donc c'était comme
ça que je suis arrivé je suis arrivé
chez mon oncle du côté de ma mère à
l'époque c'était à coulommiers et c'est
là bas que j'ai commencé à jouer au
basket et puis et puis après le défilé
en aiguille je suis rentré à châtenay
malabry à torcy et puis après le son de
formation de chalon et puis après ben
alors affiché chalon c'est vraiment une
histoire d'amour entre vous et ce club
vous y êtes restés de nombreuses saisons
oui bien sûr dh lui c'est grâce à
challenges suis devenu français par le
biais du président dominique jeu qui a
pris sa retraite il ya un mois
maintenant de cela et je tiens à lui
faire un petit coucou est aussi vraiment
un challenge et j'ai tout connu là bas
c'est vraiment la maison j'ai appris à
devenir sportif de haut niveau gd venir
être un angle j'ai rencontré énormément
de personnes et puis c'est là que ma
carrière vraiment s est elle a commencé
quoi et je pourrai jamais oublier ces
clubs là et je ne cherchais remercier
monsieur collin qui était mon proviseur
de mon école qui a vraiment tout fait
pour moi j'avais vraiment beaucoup pas
pas la boire et puis bien sûr mais
l'entraîneur gregor beugnot vincent
lavandier philippe sudre enfin j'en
passe des noms mais voilà pour moi ce
sera toujours ma maison la barre et je
reviens quand je vais là-bas et donc
voilà
all star game français notamment oui
bien sûr en 2001 en 2004 ici en france
j'en ai fait aussi en turquie à chypre
mais c'est vrai que c'est assez
exceptionnel de pouvoir le vivre ici à
paris devant 25000 personnes devant ma
famille et en sachant que j'avais 18 ans
donc on ne sait pas trop ce qui nous
arrive est donc voila c'était c'était
une belle expérience avait alors votre
carrière à vous a emmené un petit peu
partout en europe et notamment en italie
ou au tout début racontez nous
c'était c'était une expérience quand
même un jeu aussi jeune oui bien sûr
c'était c'était assez particulier dans
le sens où c'est la première fois que je
m'exile est enfin je veux dire de
quitter le cocon familial est d'ailleurs
encore en italie en sachant que j'étais
hyper jeunes et à riquet l'âge une
vingtaine d'années vers 19 ans j'avais
19 ans et d'être dans un contexte où
bella j'étais plus jeune du club j'étais
plutôt un joueur étranger donc on
attendait de moi beaucoup de
performances et puis après il fallait
s'adapter à la danse adaptées au pays
s'adapter au contexte et ce n'était pas
simple au début j'ai failli me faire
virer de ce club là mais heureusement
ils ont été patient avec moi et puis
après la sicile 1 je le précise
exactement exactement et puis après par
la suite ça s'est bien passé alors vous
avez joué dans plusieurs clubs à chypre
1 vous l'avez a mentionné précédemment
en espagne en turquie
qu'est ce que ces expériences à
l'étranger vous en rapporter
une manière de voir le basket
différemment ça m'a apporté aussi
énormément de culture et puis aussi
comme je dis toujours moi ce n'était pas
de ma volonté de forcément changer de
club après l'aspect financier qui était
aussi important qu'il fallait voir et
être dans un club qui avait un projet
qui correspondait aussi aux joueurs
parce que c'est toujours un alliage d2d
dans un club qui voilà qui ont projet
collectif pour le pour le club et d'être
aussi avec des entraîneurs les
partenariats qui on peut bien 130 bien
jouer au basket donc non voilà pour moi
c'est un ensemble de choses et je
regrette pas du tout je regarde pas du
tout dans quel club vous avez pris le
plus de plaisir à l'étranger je dirais
turc et turcs et à bon rythme c'est un
très très grand club là bas maintenant
ce club-là n'existe plus depuis deux ans
à cause du comider énormément de crise
et est donc ce club n'existe plus
tout simplement parce que c'est un club
qui était très très professionnelle à
tous les niveaux et c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui se fait au même niveau
de la nba il avait énormément d'argent
et je me rappelle en avait des joueurs
dans cette équipe là qui touchait un
million deux c'est un ancien joueur qui
joue en nba
donnez-leur vais donc non voilà c'était
quand même impressionnant de le voir
après le pays était particulier parce
que la langue elle est compliquée en
turquie les gens parlent pas forcément
français ni anglais on était dans un
petit village un peu là-bas avons vite
donc moi j'avais signé un contrat de
deux ans mais au bout d'un an c'était
difficile pour moi de rester parce que
voilà le le plus important ce n'est pas
forcément donné qu'elle l'argent c'est
aussi prendre du plaisir et puis la vie
extérieure aussi elle est aussi
importante
puis arrive monaco c'est peut-être la
meilleure expérience de votre carrière
là où vous êtes le plus
développé sur le terrain où vous avez pu
apporter à l'équipe oui oui bien sûr
parce que pour le projet de monaco
c'était un projet qui était très
alléchant surtout que c'est un club qui
est en national une à l'époque est à -
étant donné que j'ai toujours j'en
conviens division c'était ce n'était pas
simple d'accepter ce projet là mais je
savais que ça vienne vraiment une
volonté réelle dalle en première
division
après ils ont mis tous les moyens qu'il
fallait pour pour que ce club aussi
arriver à ce projet et voilà vivent à
monaco jouer là bas c'est enfin le sud
le soleil c'était quelque chose que
qu'on pouvait pas refuser même s'il y
avait beaucoup de pression sur le dos
mais voilà je suis content avec maison
5o qui périt qui on a pu vraiment relevé
ce projet du club les a menés en
première division et puis quand on voit
monaco aujourd'hui à l'échelle
internationale qui vont en euroligue ils
font partie des meilleurs clubs cette
année en euroligue donc c'est quand même
impressionnant à voir puisqu'il faut pas
l'oublier ça fait que huit ans que
monaco est partie de la nationale 1 et
se retrouve en euroligue donc c'est
quand même un parcours qui est
exceptionnel c'est là vous avez produit
votre meilleur basket à votre avis non
pas forcément c'est différent c'est
différent après ce qu'était ce qui était
plus attachant c'est monter un club de
trois niveaux c'était ça qui était
beaucoup plus exceptionnel et puis on a
tissé des liens avec énormément de
personnes à bord mais voilà chaque
expérience elle est différente et
procure des choses qui sont différentes
donc donc voilà vous n'êtes jamais allé
en nba vous qui êtes un fan de ce
championnat est ce que c'est un petit
regret ou finalement le chemin s'est
fait comme ça honnêtement je n'ai pas de
regrets parce que je pense que je
pouvais pas leur nba honnêtement même si
au départ de ma carrière il y avait
énormément de personnes qui me croyais
en nba je pense que j'étais trop petit
pour la nba et fallait devant max et
pioneer en termes d' adresse déjà et 1
par rapport à ma tête j'étais trop petit
je pense pour la nba combien 1 m 80 m 80
et puis il faut pas oublier que les
meneurs nba font quand même 90 en
général ça joue vachement grand les
intérêts à fin 2010 2015 2020 et ça va
hyper hyper vite donc voilà j'ai eu la
chance de faire quelques work out nba
avec des équipes comme chicago comme
milwaukee j'ai fait la summer league au
6 mai mais j'ai aucun regret par rapport
à une bien je pense que c'était pas ce
n'était pas de mon destin des deux mains
destinée alors vous êtes un grand fan de
kobe bryant on vous l'avait dit en début
d'entretien est ce que vous regardez un
petit peu ce qu'il a pu faire dans sa
carrière sa façon de bouger sur le
terrain ce que vous avez un petit peu
copié pas copier parce que bon on joue
pas vraiment la même position mais en
tout cas son état d'esprit j'ai copié
parce que c'est un gars qui a été très
professionnelle et qui avait un mythique
de travail qui était exceptionnel donc
bien sûr kobe symbolise ce qu'un athlète
en général de représenter la en
particulier un basketteur donc bien sûr
j'ai grandi avec lui et puis encore là
récemment d'apprendre sa mort c'était
c'était bouleversant pour nous tous
parce qu'il nous a impacté à tous les
niveaux un paquet les basketteurs tous
les sports en général je pense et donc
voilà il a en tout cas là il aura laissé
quelque chose de magnifique pour nous
tous alors vous avez également une
expérience internationale avec la
république centrafricaine
pourquoi cette sélection plutôt que
l'équipe de france avec laquelle vous
avez évolué dans les équipes jeunes au
départ au départ j'ai l'opportunité joue
en équipe junior et puis après espoir et
puis faut se dire la vérité la
concurrence et était vachement et moi
moi j'étais dans une période lui avec
tony parker qui était déjà maintenant de
cette équipe là et tony a été déjà en
nba donc donc je voyais bien que pour
moi c'était compliqué d'intégrer cette
équipe de france là donc naturellement
avec mes parents on a opté de jouer pour
mon pays d'origine que la centrafrique
et je pense que j'ai fait le bon choix
parce que je ne pouvais pas compter
dessus à ce moment là avec un garçon
comme tony parker qui vraiment a
révolutionné le basket français donc
donc voilà je suis fier d'avoir
représenté mon pays d'origine et d avoir
aidé au maximum est ce que vous êtes
fiers de votre parcours cette sélection
notamment de nombreuses cannes
1,5 je crois aux 6 ou et 5 tonnes 5
adobe mitigé mitigé pour la simple
raison qu'on avait une très très bonne
équipe une génération avec des joueurs
comme romain sato régis koundjia junior
pellois max congrès c'est vraiment des
joueurs qui rentrent en jeu ici en
europe et je pense que si on a une
meilleure organisation au sein de la
fédération c'est avec un de basket ball
on aurait pu remporter voire deux ou
trois cannes ce qu'on n'a pas fait leur
gré les rames ou là et c'est dommage
vous avez un souvenir en particulier sur
cette expérience avec la république
centrafricaine qui vous mentent
oui j'ai un souvenir la première fois je
suis retourné en centrafrique en 2009
depuis que j'étais parti et j'ai reçu un
accueil du peuple alors qu'ils étaient
exceptionnelles parce que je vous fais
moi je me rendais pas compte qu fait tim
bray à la télé est joué et s'est passé
sur canal et ou moi je mens n'est pas du
tout content et quand je suis arrivée à
l'aéroport j'ai vu le nombre de
personnes qui m'attendait et qui ont
appelé mon nom est tous et c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui m'a procuré
beaucoup de frissons et puis aussi sur
les sur les terrains il était vraiment
des vrais fans quoi
vous avez rejoint le fc trappes en 2019
pourquoi cette équipe finnoise parce que
déjà j'habite dans la région et c'est
une belle région les yvelines c'est un
club qui me tient particulièrement à
coeur parce que ils ont un projet de
vouloir monter ce club-là en troisième
division nationale une aujourd'hui on en
nationale 3 et
mon ami nasser justement qu'ils viennent
à manager de ce club-là et cyril à mes
jeunes qui est l'entraîneur voilà on est
tous voilà dévoué pour pouvoir aider ce
projet là et c'est vrai que ianoukovitch
y arriver hum
ça s'est bien passé l'année dernière
finalement la saison et arrêté
l'installant commence mal la saison et
voilà mon objectif c'est vraiment
d'essayer d'amener ce club là en
troisième division et puis après
derrière je pourrai prendre ma retraite
sereinement mais j'ai vraiment envie de
voir un club dans les yvelines en
troisième division parce que je pense
que la région le mérite fortement on n'a
aucun club aujourd'hui à parfois si qui
en nationale 2 qui en nationale une donc
donc voilà on va tout mettre en oeuvre
pour pouvoir y arriver vous vous sentez
bien en tout cas je me sens bien je me
sens bien jamais bien les personnes
qu'ils y sont et franchement ça se passe
bien merci michael mokongo et bonne
chance pour la suite de votre carrière
si beaucoup c'était un plaisir de tagro
[Musique]